wie ist ihre Einschätzung zu diesem
Vorschlag er spricht oder auch viele
andere Kritik die heute zu hören war
spricht davon Sippenhaft ist in
Deutschland verboten würden Sie sagen
dass es auch ein Vorschlag der ist
einfach gar nicht so umzusetzen
ja die Kritik aus dem Chat hat
vollkommen recht aber das liegt auch
daran dass im Gesetzentwurf von der
sittenhaft überhaupt nicht die Rede ist
das heißt da wird in gewisser Weise auf
Windmühlen eingeschlagen da wird so
getan als ob ein Gesetz was drin steht
was gar nicht drin steht und es ist
nicht die Schuld ihres Users sondern es
teilweise auch der Schuld der Medien die
hier jetzt etwas hinein lesen was nicht
drin steht der Begriff der glänzt zum
Beispiel steht in dem Gesetzentwurf mit
keinem Wort drinne stattdessen ist dort
die Rede von der Mitgliedschaft in der
kriminellen Vereinigung sie haben das
eingangs erwähnt und es ist eindeutig
dass eine große Zugehörigkeit zu einer
Familie nicht ausreicht um in dem Sinne
einer kriminellen Vereinigung
anzugehören da brauchte eine aktive
Mitgliedschaften dazugehören und der
Umstand dass ein Bruder oder auch
Cousins Straftaten begehen oder selber
sondern kriminellen Vereinbarung
Vereinigung angehören reicht nicht aus
es braucht eine Einzelfallprüfung also
Sippenhaft wird es selbst wenn der
Gesetzentwurf kommt so nicht geben
ein weiterer user-kommentar lautet hier
von einem User Userin nennt sich l.ike
bei Youtube na klar ist das gut aber was
sagt das Grundgesetz
ist Grundgesetz würde hier icke
vollkommen Recht geben also eine
sittenhaft dass man Leute dafür mit in
Haftung nimmt was ihre Verwandten tun
dass der mit dem Grundgesetz nicht
vereinbart nur noch mal der steht auch
in dem Gesetzentwurf in keinster Weise
drin das muss in einer Einzelfallprüfung
nachgewiesen werden dass diese Person
einer kriminellen Vereinigung angehört
und nur dann greift dieser neue
Gesetzentwurf und dabei geht es dann
zuerst auch mal nur um die Ausweisung
die Abschiebung ist dann noch mal eine
andere Frage das ist eine nachgelagerte
Sache was man besonders prüfen muss
sehen Sie noch weitere Hürden in diesem
Vorschlag oder ist das jetzt schon der
Hauptkritikpunkt
ja absolut ihr Gast im Studio hat vorhin
kurz mittelbar erwähnt ich meine diese
Clans sind oft schon seit vielen
Jahrzehnten in Deutschland und das führt
dazu dass vor allem die jüngeren
Mitglieder dieser Familien häufig
bereits den deutschen passern und werden
deutschen Pass hat den kann man auch
nach dem neuen Gesetzentwurf nicht
abschieben das ist einfach nicht möglich
das sind Deutsche und die dürfen in
Deutschland leben und zwar unabhängig
davon ob sie noch einen anderen Pass
haben oder nicht und es ist nur ein
Problem es kommt noch was zweites hinzu
es geht bei dem Gesetzentwurf nur um die
Ausweisung und das heißt den Verlust des
Aufenthaltstitels das heißt die Menschen
sind dann wenn er Ausweisung erfolgreich
ist formal rechtswidrig in Deutschland
sie müssen das Land verlassen das heißt
aber noch nicht dass man sie automatisch
abschieben darf ob das der Fall ist oder
nicht muss man besonders prüfen da ist
ein separates Verfahren durchzuführen
und zu kommt dann noch was drin ist auch
nach dem neuen Gesetzentwurf ist so eine
Ausweisung also die Wegnahme des
Aufenthaltstitels die jemand hat nicht
ohne weiteres möglich sondern es braucht
da auch in Zukunft eine umfassen
computerabwägung wo man das Pro und
Contra miteinander abbiegt und da sind
die Gerichte auch sehr streng man muss
berücksichtigen wie lange jemand da lebt
ob er hier Familie hat wie guter
integriert ist da gibt es also überhaupt
kein Automatismus alles was der
Gesetzentwurf sagt ist dass er eben
vorgibt dass bei dieser umfassenden
Einzelfallprüfung Güterabwägung der
Umstand dass meiner kriminellen
Vereinigung angehört etwas mehr wiegt
ausgewiesen und erst recht abgeschoben
wird deswegen niemand automatisch
es gibt auch einige Stimmen bei uns im
Stream die vermuten dass dieser
Vorschlag jetzt nur eine Stimmungsmache
vor der Wahl in Hessen ist mit der Nancy
Ferse auffallen möchte ein User Userin
BK schreibt bei Facebook also ich
behaupte einfach mal frei das ist ein
ungeeigneter Versuch war sich ins
Gespräch zu bringen mehr nicht dass das
so nicht funktioniert sollte gerade ihr
klar sein vermuten sie das auch dass das
eine sehr undurchdachter in dem Falle
Vorschlag war weil eigentlich kommt der
ja tatsächlich wir haben es vorhin schon
angesprochen eben auch von Länder und
Kommunen und auch nicht in erster
Instanz von jetzt dem Innenministerium
ich glaube wir müssen da wirklich zwei
Dinge auseinanderhalten das eine ist der
Gesetzentwurf als solcher der eben auf
diese Beratung auch auf Wünsche vom Bund
und Ländern und Kommunen zurückgeht und
das Frau Feser das jetzt kurz vor dem
Wahlkampf macht das kann man kritisieren
andererseits kritisieren sie auch manche
dafür dass sie so viele Monate gebraucht
hat uns nicht schneller gemacht hat das
ist das eine aber bei dieser ganz
konkreten Vorschrift das jetzt hier die
Ausweisung wohlgemerkt nicht Abschiebung
von Mitgliedern krimineller Vereinigung
etwas erleichtert werden soll da
vermutlich überhaupt keine Strategie
freiarbeiter in der öffentlichen Debatte
etwas aufgebaut wird was so in keiner
Weise im Gesetz drin steht und auch ganz
sicher nicht intendiert war also diese
Debatte um um jetzt Kriminalität das ist
kein irgendwie abgekartetes Spiel
gewesen weil ich denke da ist jetzt
wirklich welches zu sagen dafür im
Sommer auch etwas aufgebaut worden was
zu groß gar nicht ist sie haben gerade
einen Unterschied gemacht Ausweisung
versus abschie bung können Sie uns da
auch noch mal ganz konkret sagen was es
dabei zu beachten gilt was ist der
Unterschied
Abschiebung das sind Begriffe die
verwendet man verwechselt man sehr
leicht weiß beides irgendwas mit
Verlassen des Landes zu tun hat aber es
sind zwei durchaus unterschiedliche
Dinge Abschiebungen ist der Rhein
tatsächlich Vorgang dass man jemand der
in Deutschland sich bisher auffällt ich
sag mal ganz Platz außer landesschaft
also weg bringt zwangsweise in ein
anderes Land zurückführt das ist die
Abschiebung und die Ausweisung ist das
vorgelagertes da geht es um Menschen die
sich eigentlich rechtmäßig in
Deutschland aufhalten den Männern aber
die Erlaubnis wegnimmt hier zu leben das
nennt man juristisch gesehen die
Ausweisung das ist aber nur der erste
Schritt als nächstes kommt dann die
Abschiebung das ist aber besonders das
Verfahren und diese Ausweisung also die
Wegnahme des Aufenthaltstitels braucht
doch nur dann wenn jemand an sich sich
ja aufhalten darf bei Menschen deren
Asylantrag abgelehnt wird da braucht man
diesen Schritt überhaupt nicht weil wenn
der Asylantrag abgelehnt wird das ja
auch eine Gruppe um die ist vielfach
geht dann darf man ohnehin abschieben
ganz ohne Ausweisung
danke dass Sie das noch mal klarer
gemacht haben aber auf eine Sache würde
ich gerne noch mal eingehen weil sie
sagen vielleicht wird das hier gerade
aufgebaut und Sommerloch schauen wir
vielleicht noch mal rein ich habe es
eingangs in der Sendung schon mal
gemacht schauen wir also noch mal in
dieses Diskussionspapier und hier ich
hatte es vorhin zitiert also an dieser
Stelle steht ja schon ziemlich eindeutig
worum es da geht also es soll eben an
den diese knüpft über den Strafbestand
des Paragraph 129 Strafgesetzbuch
Bildung krimineller Vereinigung an die
Angehörigkeit zu einer solchen solchen
Gemeinschaft an und ist unabhängig von
einer strafrechtlichen Verurteilung da
steht's aber schon ziemlich genau drin
oder genau darum geht wenn die Behörden
nachweisen können und zwar also
strafrechtliche Verurteilung da sind die
Strafgerichte die eine Strafe
aussprechen und in dem Fall geht es
nicht darum auch wenn die strafgerichtet
keine Strafe ausgesprochen haben können
die Ausländerbehörden also andere
Behörden zu dem Ergebnis kommen dass die
Person dennoch einer kriminellen
Vereinigung angehört ohne dass das
bisher rechtlich verfolgt worden wäre
das dürfen Sie sich aber nicht ausdenken
sondern da müssen sie auch Gründe
darlegen und diese Gründe sind im
Zweifelsfall auch vor den
Verwaltungsgerichten auch wieder andere
Gerichte als Strafgerichte überprüfbar
das heißt wir brauchen nur vorgelagert
keinen strafurtteil welches schon
festgestellt hat dass jemand einer
kriminellen Vereinigung angehört da
müssten ja auch die Ausländerbehörden
gar nichts mehr prüfen dann wäre es ja
schon festgestellt sondern auch wenn wir
kein strafurtteil haben dürfen die
Ausländerbehörden des eigenständig
prüfen müssen das dann aber auch
darlegen wie gesagt wenn im Zweifelsfall
wird das von den Gerichten überprüft und
das zeigt Ihnen auch das ist alles fest
in den Rechtsstaat
eingerichtet und auch um noch mal eine
andere Sache ganz klar zu machen was
schon auch vom der Sprecherin des
Ministeriums auf Nachfrage der
Süddeutschen Zeitung bestätigt wurde
also es geht hier schon auch ganz klar
um Angehörige sogenannter Clanstrukturen
das hat sie so gesagt also es geht darum
Angehörigen sogenannter Clanstrukturen
um die künftig leichter abschieben zu
können also meint das Innenministerium
ja doch ganz klar klar richtig
genau aber wenn das Innenministerium
meinte das mit diesem Gesetzentwurf alle
Mitglieder dieser sogenannten Clans
einfach aus der Landes geschafft werden
dürfen dann würde es irren dann hätte es
hier etwas vorgeschlagen was sozusagen
die Juristen formulierenden untauglicher
Versuch ist das Ziel was man da
politisch essen will hat würde mit dem
Gesetzentwurf jedenfalls überhaupt nicht
erreicht werden bei der steht da
schlichtweg nicht drinne wir brauchen im
Einzelfall nachweisbar eine
Zugehörigkeit zu einer kriminellen
Vereinigung und die bloße Verwandtschaft
dass man Brüder Cousins hat die im
größeren Umfang Straftaten begehen ist
für sich genommen ganz garantiert nichts
was die Behörden und erst rechtliche
Gerichte anerkennen würden als etwas was
in dem Sinne eine Ausweisung
rechtfertigt ganz abgesehen davon dass
man da noch all die zusätzlichen
Prüfungspunkte hatte ich vorher erwähnt
habe also wenn das Ministerium meint mit
dem Gesetzentwurf wirklich alle
Mitglieder von klangfamilien abschieben
zu dürfen dann hätten sie sich nicht
geirrte steht dort nicht drin